over the past five or six years we have
explored offering degree programs
outside of Pittsburgh in some cases
outside of the United States
we now have various professional masters
programs in eight countries and these
are being pursued with a number of
different pedagogical approaches but in
each case with a high degree of quality
a high degree of satisfaction by our
partners they represent these programs
represent a wonderful platform for us to
engage ourselves with the rest of the
world cybersecurity is a global issue
and cybersecurity does not have national
borders so the issues that we need to
address here on the in the United States
are very similar to issues in other
countries most of the times they need to
be tackled as a as a collaboration
amongst nations because it involves
policies and laws international laws
laws of one particular nation and really
if you think about the internet it's an
it's a millions of nodes across the
world are connected and so where do you
where do you put the boundary by nation
it's just not possible the goal of the
International Programs of the
information networking Institute are to
partner strategically partner with other
academic institutions that have an area
of strength that is important to our
programs so for example we have
partnered with Athens information
technology in Athens Greece since 2002
their strength is in telecommunication
so they were a natural partner in
addition to that engineering and
telecommunications expertise that they
have we provide courses and coursework
and for example in strategy coming out
of engineering and the engineering and
public policy department here so we're
able to disseminate that kind of
knowledge that they don't have
and we combine our two areas of
expertise into the sum of the total
product which is our graduate program
the master of science and information
networking because of this model of
collaborating with other faculty from
other institutions we're able to scale
our programs and expand into other
geographic areas currently we have
programs in Athens Greece Kobe Japan and
next year we are going to launch new
programs in a very Portugal in Lisbon
Portugal instruction is shared in that
faculty from the University of Lisbon
for example can also teach courses and
security they have existing research
collaborations with our faculty here in
scilab so the connection already exists
and here they're able to expand their
collaboration in their research through
this educational partnership